why did you write a book about happiness
I wrote a book about happiness because
the Stoics had really resonated with me
I was I like I I studied law I was
supposed to be a lawyer and I graduated
and I kind of was living in Bristol this
lovely city in England and making my
living as a magician because I wasn't
the hobby that it I'd started and I was
just kind of thinking what I need to
some point would this just grow into a
job I don't know but I I know that my
priorities are just kind of I want my
life my days to feel like this is good
everything's in the right place and this
is kind of an enjoyable and worthwhile
pastime and that was while existence and
I never really thought beyond that so
I've never had any kind of ambition
genuinely a bit of any any sort which is
why you know I don't really I'm not have
a whole goal-setting thing particularly
so but the trouble with thinking like
that as you grow up and become
successful with what you do is you start
to feel like a kid like everyone else
has have grown up and you're the kid and
and you've slightly embarrassed that you
don't seem to care enough about the
things that everybody else cares about
mmm the businessí things and the viewing
figures and then this I my interest was
genuinely am i enjoying what I'm doing
and is it worthwhile and then I read the
Stoics and although that's not like
their central message it's a big part of
their what they write about you know not
not trying to control things that are
out of your control not attaching
yourself to things that leave you kind
of emotionally kind of vulnerable and
you know just your relationship to the
present moment and so on and it really
resonated so I I read up I read a lot
and it took me off into other directions
and I started writing and I wrote this
book on happiness after it took me three
years to write it while I was on tour so
three years but blocks of blocks of
writing not like three solid years but
also that meant by the end of it I kind
of had grown and changed and felt
differently and I think for anyone that
knows about stoicism and it's so
immensely valuable resource in terms of
if what you want is a sense of feeling
centered and a kind of emotional
robustness in your life and you know if
you suffer from anxiety and so it's it's
it's phenomenal I think they wear it
wear it slightly doesn't deliver is the
importance of anxiety it's all about
avoiding anxiety that
image of happiness was a sort of
tranquility avoiding disturbance that
actually cause disturbance is really
important anxiety is important in life
because how do you change how do you
grow other than you know unless some
anxiety triggers that you know lets you
know that something's wrong yes we just
look for security all the time and I say
this because I know I'm like this like
this is my my problem is that I'm too
I'm very good at avoiding stress very
good avoiding anxiety but the dangerous
I am I gonna grow I'll you know I'm just
gonna just be too comfortable that's not
you know that's not necessarily a good
thing so so yeah by the end of the book
I was I kind of could feel the edges of
stoicism in terms of the importance of
anxiety and you know and not just living
too comfortably but it is it is a and
that's not yeah they were movers and
shakers like there are people that
change the worlds Marcus Aurelius you
know greatest philosopher King really
was an emperor most powerful man and
ever was probably ruled the earth and
was a was a one of the great Stoics so
they're not like it's not a recipe for
complacency which you can often sound
like when you talk about this kind of
tranquility and non-attachment
but it is it's it's it's just it's a
very robust kind of language they talk
about being like a rock where the waves
are lashing against you and I I prefer
the image of this sort of I don't if you
know Martha Nussbaum who's a American
philosopher writes a lot about these
things but she she talks about being
more porous like a rock that the the
waves the water can move through and I
think that's a more helpful image I
think that's a that's a good way I think
of stepping out into life is if you can
have a a sort of a robustness but at the
same time they're kind of an easy porous
relationship with what's going on that
gives you that easier relationship to
fate and fortune and all those things
that they used to honor and recognize so
much more than we do now because we
don't read tragedy so we don't think in
terms of those things it's all just you
know pride and hubris now that they had
lessons about back then and you know but
I think that's a very I think that's it
that's a good that's a good starting
point for life so I wrote I wrote this
book happy it is it's actually just
become available in the in the US on
Amazon I don't think you'll find it any
book shops but um
because of the I company hope you're
doing a Broadway show next year and
these Netflix specials and things that
you know so they it is now available and
and ironically the moment I finished
writing it I was out giving talks on
happiness feeling oddly sad and I
couldn't work out why it was because
this amazing three-year writing project
it ended and I realized yeah I the
importance of some kind of creative
pursuit or something that brings you out
of yourself is so important that's
fascinating that in the embracing of the
anxiety of the difficulty of the task
and finding upon its completion that you
feel sad oddly oddly sad well it's kind
of proof of concept that yeah right I
mean what you're saying is to like in
this theme that you keep saying over and
over again that putting yourself into
something bigger than you something
something that you're you're attempting
to work through and that through this
difficulty and all the struggle and
trying to put this something you you
gain some sort of intangible benefit
from this mmm
you feel like you seem like you're
someone that seeks out those things you
seem you know you've always like immerse
yourself fully and things that would it
would do that yes I'm a firm believer in
the importance of difficult tasks I
think I think seeking comfort is one of
the worst things a person can do in
terms of achieving overall happiness I
think overall happiness a lot of it
comes through this amazing sense of
wonder and the unknown and possibilities
and working towards things with this
embracing of you know having no idea how
that what the result is going to be no
idea where this is gonna go and being
genuinely nervous about it every step of
the way and you find that goes normally
being having the language for something
means that it doesn't come naturally
because if that came in charlie
naturally all the things I'm saying if
they completely just I'd always been
like that you wouldn't have the language
the entirely unconscious so you found
this is stuff that you've found and then
learn to articulate but because that's
not it's not an easy thing it's not a
not an intuitive thing that maybe life
is is essentially difficult and on these
lovely happy moments we have are
wonderful but they're not the kind of
they're not the central force of life
which is that it is it is difficult not
if you want a philosophy of life it has
to work in those has to work at the
different moment otherwise it's not
really it's not really gonna support you
I think it's also the attitude in which
you embrace those difficult moments and
how you approach them you know if you if
you relish them and and understand that
there's going to be some genuine benefit
from getting through these and whether
it's a physical thing or a mental thing
whether it's a creative thing whatever
it is it's difficult like just embrace
this massive struggle and enjoy this
just the puzzle of it all the majesty of
the unknown and then when you get
through it on the other end you get a
different level of happiness yeah you
have this powerful earned happy because
you grow yeah you don't cross the road
on your own without having to let go of
your mother's hand at some point yeah
something this is this is the death and
resurrection isn't it that's why these
myths do have some resonance yeah
something has to die before something
new before something you can grow you
have to something has to be let go of in
order to step forward so if you're gonna
grow you have to there has to be anxiety
and disturbance and some kind of some
sort of death in the metaphorical sense
know if there's toughest and doesn't
come easily no it does it come easily
but that's also what's beautiful about
it if it just came easily I don't think
you'd be appreciated exactly you
wouldn't be doing it and there's all
this resistance to even engage in in the
first place it's hard to write the first
word of a book write the first word
sometimes you're just sitting there or
anything you're trying to do get it the
first step of a 10 mile run all those
things are the most difficult thing once
you once you're going it's not nearly as
hard it's getting going there's
something about overcoming all this
anticipation and although the weirdness
of it all you know and then once you do
it and you realize you can do it it
enriches you in all your future attempts